bailén anunció precisamente acuerdos
colaboración con la empresa privada para
evitar estos retrasos en la cadena de
suministro retrasos que según muchos
críticos está ayudando a generar está
inflación que vive el país y es triste
lo mencionado al puerto de los ángeles
es por donde entra la mayor cantidad de
productos importados de china y del este
de asia y esto pues está generando
entonces que se muchos contenidos muchos
barcos queden anclados sin poder
descargar sus productos a este puerto
entonces byd en lo que está trabajando y
anunciando es acuerdos para que no
solamente el puerto de los ángeles sino
el puerto de long beach y también
empresas como fedex como target como
wall mart que son las que más se
distribuyen los productos al interior
del país trabajen
24/7 y también anunció acuerdos con los
sindicatos para que aseguren la mano de
obra en estos puertos y se haga un
trabajo conjunto de redistribución de
descargue y pues se pueda evitar una
crisis aún más severa no solamente para
el black friday en noviembre sino
también para y siempre para las
vacaciones de diciembre cuando muchas
familias pues empiezan a hacer sus
órdenes en línea y se acumula aún más
problemas productos en los puertos